يعني رحمه الله عليك انا انسان طيب وانسان
اعطى كثير من حياته للفن وهذا يعني
نعتبر علم من اعلامنا ورحمه الله عليه كفه
ووفى هذا مصاب ليس لاسره
الايقونه عبد الكريم عبد القادر انما مصاب
لكل محبينه كل الناس اللي عاشوا معاه سواء
كاصدقاء او محبين له لفنه الجميل يوم
فقدنا عمود من اعمده الفن الكويتي
وتاريخ يعتبر ايقونه كويتيه قدم الكثير
وعدم الاعمال خاصه الاعمال اللي قدمها
والاعمال الوطنيه واعمال خاصه ايضا قدم
الفن الكويتي بشكل مختلف عن عن جيله
اغانيه راسخه في اذهاننا الاغنيه الوطنيه
والاغنيه الاجتماعيه وافتقدوا محبين على
المستوى المحلي
المستوى الخليجي والعربي كان نموذج للفن
الراقي وتعامله واخلاقه كان بيني وبينه
تواصل في واحد خمسه
الفين
لما احنا درينا انه هو في المستشفى طبعا
وتعبان فطلب من عندنا عدم نشر اي شيء
علشان ما يعني يضيق خلق الشعب الكويتي
وقال رحمه الله عليه اذا رده وطلع من
المستشفى راح يكون هو راح يعني
يتكلم بهذا الامر ويشكر كل من يسال عنه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات